okay so last time we talked I asked you
if you were gonna do anything like a la
Destiny's Child in the 2000 that you
said I've got something on my voice oh I
got some stuff up my sleeve okay yes I
know right I delivered I mean come on
how do I see Ariana delivered that's who
deliver how did this trio come together
ariana grande came in really early on to
executive produced the soundtrack for
the movie I was really obsessed with the
Black Panther soundtrack and how one
artist sort of like took over and really
represented not just the theme of the
movie but the audience for the movie and
she's so perfect and she really loves
Charlie's Angels and it's she's gonna
dream and so I mean it really she's
friends with Miley Miley came in pretty
click on that song that song was one of
the first things we heard from the album
producers and we loved it I loved the
how and Emma kit was and then figuring
out Lana's part and how they could sort
of combine all their different styles
which is totally the theme of the movie
I have three totally different angels
and three totally different incredible
singers and and just that it all came
together I'm blown away I love that have
now have these angels methines some of
the angels have met the other angels I
think last time we talked we didn't know
if this was gonna be a remake or a
reboot but it really is it's set in the
same universe correct it's just a
continuation of everything that's come
before so the angels from the drew Lucy
and Cameron that that trio
they exist in our world they they were
angels they still are angels the
original angels are we're still angels
and Charlie's still Charlie and Bosley
he's just a rank now instead of an
actual person like bond a little bit
yeah could could those angels cameo
watch the movie yeah but I like your
hints I'm like the next time we talk
maybe you'll have more information yeah
hey there you have it thank you so much
congratulations
[Music]